when you enter cenote it's really like
going into another world like living
leaving the planet behind
this is
feeling of really exploring something
new
and i feel very lucky to be able to see
that
my name is uh julian bird i've been free
diving and scuba diving for the last 15
years we're in many different locations
always trying to find the best diving
spots
those cenotes are archives
all those denotes are connected to each
other and the the water goes and flows
from one senate to another cenote to end
up in the sea
the first time you you go into cenotes
it's something you don't see anywhere
else it's completely a different
experience than diving in the ocean
at the beginning it can be a little bit
scary
but really quickly the beauty of the
place would just take over
some cenotes are very welcoming
sometimes so big and so clear that it
really gives you the sensation you go
into a church and you don't want to talk
too loud to not disturb anyone
and some of the cenotes i also have a
little bit like an atmosphere more like
hell with
dead trees in the bottom and sulfur
the mayans were using the cenotes
for a very long time
basically the land where we are that's
the place where the living people lives
and then underneath the cenotes into the
ground was the place for the dead
every single day i have a different
personality
but i also think that he really affects
your own personality
at some point you
kind of enter into like a meditation
state that's for me is
completely priceless
you